settle this once and for all easy don't
cross streams here let's set up let's
settle this once and for all uh Megan
Fox with a penis or or Hulk Hogan with a
vagina go ahead both of you
[Applause]
but he has all the prestiges just stop
it nope you have to answer the question
hear me out on this Hulk Hogan with a
penis
come on he's
he's the hulkster brother he literally
just wants to be in a bed with Hulk
Hogan
yeah I mean look there's there's few men
in life that you know you can't say no
no Hulk Hogan it's like you're that's
your whole 80s and 90s right there it's
almost your patriotic Duty
um I'm gonna also go with uh man I'm
gonna go with the Hulk Hogan with a
vagina how about this Megan Fox with two
penises it's too many people I'm glad
that we actually have we have Universal
agreement here we all went with Hulk
Hogan I went with Hulk Hogan yesterday
the hulkster of course I mean come on
he's a real American he's a literal icon
yeah come on
I hey we're all we're all in the same
bed now literally with this one and
there's enough Hulk for all of us to go
around I suppose